- Any pet owner knows that dogs
can quickly become an
important part of the family.
We like to take them along
for the ride whenever we can.
It's probably okay to leave
them in the car, right?
Let's ask some people
and see what they think.
All the puppies!
Say it's like a 75 degree day.
- Okay.
- How long do you think you
can leave your dog in the car?
- 20 minutes?
- Two minutes to just run in,
buy some toothpaste, and get out.
- Maybe five minutes.
- 10 minutes would even be a long time.
- Ideally, I would not
leave a dog in a car
but I think 10 minutes
with the windows down.
- 15 minutes tops.
- I don't know, like an hour?
- Look at him!
- So what happens when there's a long line
or you get distracted inside the store?
In order to understand this better,
I decided to sit in my car to
see what it really feels like.
Okay so I'm going to sit
in here for 10 minutes.
I don't have any windows cracked
but according to the AMVA,
cracking the windows actually
makes very little difference.
- Listen, the car is a
perfect storm for pets.
What we worry about is they're
not used to a really hot car.
It's humid in there
because they're panting,
there's no ventilation and a
lot of times, there's no water.
This is dangerous for pets
and dangerous in general.
- According to the thermometer,
it just hit 90 degrees in here.
- If you're getting hot, you stay calm.
That's not how dogs think.
They don't think, "I'm getting warm,
"I'm getting hot, let me be calm."
No, they get more anxious.
- I'm going to take off my jacket
because it's freaking hot.
I'm starting to sweat.
- They do sweat a little
bit between their paws,
a little bit on the top of their nose,
but that's it and so dogs
mainly cool themselves
through something called
evaporative cooling.
That means they pant.
The harder you pant, the more
worked up you're getting,
and now you're getting even hotter.
- This is terrible.
- You get a dog who's
panting, who's overheated,
kidneys can start to shut down,
we can see direct heat
damage to the brain.
Multi-organ failure is the
take home message here.
- I am starting to get like lethargic
and sleepy and sweaty and really,
really uncomfortable.
- And that's why a lot of dogs,
if you see them, they're getting hot,
you'll notice them getting more dull,
they'll seem listless, lethargic,
just not themselves.
- This is, I'm get, this
is getting so gross.
I'm so sweating and this is terrible.
- I will say this: Never
leave a dog in a hot car,
never leave the windows up,
always keep your dog out in an area
that's fully ventilated.
- All done?
10 minutes and the car is
over 95 degrees right now.
That sucks, that's terrible.
Ah, the breeze feels so good.
I'm so happy to be out of that car.
- If you do have a pet who you
think is having heat stroke,
there's some keys to preventing
the worst from happening.
Get your dog to a vet,
wrap him in cool towels,
blast the AC, and never submerge them.
- That sucks, that sucks.
It gets really hot and it
sucks even worse for pets
because they don't know what's happening.
They're just there,
miserable and confused.
- I'd rather have a vet say
to you, "Everything's fine,
"just having a little bit of heat stress,"
which is a mild form of heat stroke,
than to say, "You waited too late."
So when in doubt, go to the vet.
- So what can you do if
you see a dog in danger?
The Humane Society suggests taking down
the license plate, model,
and make of the car
and having local businesses
try to locate the pet owner
but if that doesn't work,
you can call the local,
non-emergency police
line or animal control
and wait for them by the car.
What do you have to say, Belle?
Great, just chewing the
microphone, perfect.